as I'm about to bring in the head coach
of the Detroit Lions I want to send all
of our best I'm sure nobody's out there
watching certainly if they're if they're
fleeing floodwater that's bringing up to
nine feet of water as thousands of
residents in Central Michigan Midland
County Michigan a two dam failures my
goodness the governor of the great state
of Michigan Gretchen Whitner is whitmer
is saying that the flooding is projected
to be historic and we are just
crestfallen nervous and hoping for only
the best of what's going on in the state
that I love so much because it's the
spot that that made me in many ways the
person that I am today having gone to
school there so I just wanted to say
that and bring in the head coach of the
Detroit Lions Matt Patricia here in the
Rich Eisen show how are you coach rich
how you doing I appreciate you saying
that you know it's always good to hear
your voice and great to be on with you
and certainly you know our thoughts and
prayers are with Central Michigan right
now and everybody that is dealing with
the flooding situation up there I mean
on top of everything else that's kind of
going on in our state right now you know
I know everybody is resilient in tough
but just staying strong
you know just amazing you know situation
we're gonna do I know man I know and at
some point you know we're gonna come out
of this or in the middle of all this so
many people are gonna be looking to you
and your team and saying let's go you
know they're gonna say let's go and the
question is you know at some point we'll
have to figure out the go where are you
right now and figuring out to go coach
yeah great great question um and
certainly you know we we actually talked
about that as a team quite a bit and
especially with the area with everything
that everyone's going through you know
our guys have done a great job in the
soft season of reaching out to the
community and trying to help everybody
that they can in time of need right now
and just really proud of our players for
that you know and then on top of that
we're just in the process of our
offseason program we're in the middle of
what we can set up phase two and we're
trying to keep things as normal as
possible in unnormal times you know it's
really kind of our term right now it's
just staying normal and we're in
meetings with the players you know four
days a week getting ready to finish up
our phase two at the end of the month
and then working
what we call phase three phase three
would be the biggest change for us but
usually what's commonly referred to as
OTAs we're actually out in practice and
on the field and that'll be a little bit
different right now but our players are
doing a great job staying engaged on the
calls and making sure we're doing all
the virtual teaching and learning at the
highest level we can so you know from
that standpoint we're pushing forward
and we're just going to be ready for
whatever that is that we can go we're
going to go well and in terms of that
you know right now you're in a state
where a shelter-in-place is in place for
at least another couple of weeks and
then there are other teams that are our
back-end facilities have you or anybody
from your organization called up the
league office and say that this is
something that you you hope can be
rectified if it does go longer for teams
like yourself we're certainly trying to
look at all options you know what was
most important right now is that
everybody to stay safe especially in our
area you know the two counties right now
in Wayne County in Oakland County that
have been hit really hard that's the
heart center of where you know our
facilities are and most of where our
team lives so from that standpoint you
know I have two neighbors that are
doctors our team doctor I talk to them
all the time and I can just tell by the
looks on their faces of what they're
going through being on the front lines
and having to deal with everything that
they've had to dealt with heal the last
couple months and quite frankly I think
you know from my standpoint I'm doing
everything possible to get our team
ready to go but I also you know the
health and safety of our team and
everyone in the areas is the most
important to me and I want to make sure
that we don't add to that stress by you
know just trying to rush back in a
situation that's not safe what about you
man I mean how do you draw upon anything
to try and coach through something for
which there really is no playbook yeah
oh you know a great question I just
think you know I rely heavily on my
staff I have a great staff and you know
we just kind of talk about different
ideas I've really encouraged everybody
to take this opportunity you know first
and foremost to enjoy their family and
just be blessed for what we all have and
you know the safety and the health that
everyone has right now I think that's
most important thing and then on top of
that to really try to grow grow as a
staff or as a coach think outside the
box have conversation across the ball a
little bit more call up some of your
colleagues you know see what they're
doing try to expand our knowledge to the
best of our ability so that we can pass
that on to you know to our players and
just become better coaches overall cuvee
who've you called you call anybody else
you call anybody from your past or what
do you got I'm gonna make a few phone
calls I think I know you're reaching
there but Nantucket area code I mean is
that what you know what do you think
getting ready for the draft that was
pretty interesting for myself as you're
as we're talking of you know college
coaches that were actually already in
this process you know they have already
started spring football and we're kind
of had to move to the virtual learning I
thought that was really great
conversation for me was to be able to
talk to those guys not only about their
players that were coming out but what
they were doing with their players and
how much the virtual capabilities you
know they were able to use them and push
and really I learned a lot you know from
that aspect of it and maybe you know
benefited from some of the trial and
error that they had already gone through
so from that standpoint you know that
was really neat you know really getting
ready for the draft but at the same time
we were getting ready for our own
virtual meetings that we had to have
with our players okay and you certainly
contacted Ryan day judging by your draft
that's for sure you had some
conversations with him huh you gotta try
and win football games I don't take any
offense to it I'm sure you did speak to
Jim Harbaugh at some point in time but
I'm just looking at your draft here oh
my gosh no I did actually Jim was great
we talked quite a bit we talked after
the draft but couple Buckeyes that we
brought up from from Ohio so certainly
guys that you know we thought just
really said we were trying to do and fit
some needs that we had but Brian day was
great I spoke to him obviously many
times and Jeff happy because they're one
of the defensive coaches I spoke to also
is now the head coach at Boston
so that what those are two great guys
for me to talk to in that other world
okay what are you doing with your team
right now and how you helping them learn
but there's two Buckeye editions there
okay well before I get to a kuda
specifically Matt Patricia here in the
Rich Eisen show how how much fire
potentially was there for trading out of
that three trading third overall that
was a spot where everyone was looking at
somebody was one in a you know get
nervous that the quarterback that they
wanted clearly you're not in that
business third overall how much
possibility was there for you to trade
out of that spot yeah you know honestly
there was Europe there was zero
opportunity to move and I think that if
you take a look at you know us at the
third pick and then the Giants with Joe
judging certainly Brian core is at Miami
three people that are very familiar with
each other I'll just kind of put it that
way everyone everyone kind of postured
and played their cards very well and in
the end everyone just sat where they
were and I think everyone did a good job
of understanding you know after those
first two picks were gone what everybody
was kind of interested in and from that
standpoint you know no different than
the Chargers kind of right behind that
so there was really there was no
opportunity and you know for us we were
fully prepared and ready to you know
make sure that we got the best guy that
we wanted and that certainly recruited
us why is that why was he the best guy
in your estimation third overall you
know for us at the position that we were
looking to try to help our team out with
the corner position was was one and
certainly from a skillset standpoint
we've been watching him for a while in
the conversations with Ryan Day and with
you know Jeff halfway who coach coached
their peoples last year I knew that the
fundamentals and the techniques that
that he was being prod was gonna be very
similar and almost identical to some of
the stuff that we do did a great thing
you know sometimes it's hard to really
see corners in college play press
technique not a corners playoff they put
a little bit of a quarter system and
he's a guy that you could see on tape
really get up on the receivers and
Houston press technique and place the
man-to-man so all of that on tape was
great and then to be really you know
honest with you was when we got a chance
to meet the young man and spend time
with him and find out his character his
background and just what a wonderful
person he is you know really great on
the field but even better off the field
and for us it's just about having the
right guys and having the right people
and he's one of those guys he just wants
to win he cares about being competitive
and you know really just good
characteristics behind that and then
35th overall second round you got a guy
that many people in the evaluation
community thought was the best running
back that was available in this year's
draft and DeAndre swift why did you go
in that direction coach yeah you know
for us I always think the draft right
now and how it's set up between Thursday
night and Friday night and really Friday
in this Saturday it's very interesting
there's a lot of strategy a lot of you
know analysis that goes involved with
okay what do we thinks going to happen
here you know at the top of the round
and who's going to be left as we go
through into the third round and I think
for us with him still being on the board
and Swift available it was really kind
of a situation where like hey that's you
know I can't believe he's still there
and if you still there we're going to
take them and it's going to be a really
good day so from that aspect of it it
was great for us you know I know a
quarterback was happy to get another
bulldog in the building I'm sure you
know from from that standpoint you know
Kirby's a great coach and I know him
really well down there and just you know
couldn't speak the world enough of him
so everything checked the boxes for us a
guy that we think was dynamic enough in
the run game explosive big playmaker but
also can catch the ball get out of the
backfield open up the formation and just
put a lot of pressure you know on the
defense as possible and just make those
plays that we need to be made should we
be so fortunate to get a training camp
coach will there be a competition at
that spot for the starter that running
back you know I think there's
competition in every spot that's kind of
a lot like determine when we get to
training camp you know probably pretty
sure I'm good with the quarterback spot
but beyond that you know we're going to
go out we're going to compete but I
think it's a running backs in general
you know I talk about this all the time
Neal for me we're gonna try to play
whoever's going to help us in that
particular play
particular game whatever it might be and
you know if you're out there for the
very first play you know or you get out
there on the second play I don't really
understand what the difference is
between a starter in that case you know
we got it we got carry on Johnson Cod
Johnson when we pick both garber who
helped us last year West Hills we added
last year Huntley I mean you know we'll
get those guys out there and we'll see
what happens but certainly we're excited
about you know being able to acquire
Swift and get him on our team and and
seeing what he can do you know sometimes
you put two or three running backs out
there let's see what happens we've got
the HC of the Detroit Lions Matt
Patricia for a few more minutes here on
the Rich Eisen show you've made
reference to your quarterback Matthew
Stafford a couple times in this
interview so far the real estate market
is is in the news in the state of
Michigan because of the sale of the
Stafford mats and people are reading
into all that what's is there do you
read into the real estate market coach
yeah I definitely do not read into the
real estate market unless it's uh you
know my house okay other than that I'm
I'm good I know there's a lot of things
that were out there and you know quite
frankly they were I think the word I
used was laughable that everybody was
asking me about but you know from my
standpoint Matthew Stafford and I you
know I just couldn't be more happy more
blessed to be in a situation where he's
our quarterback since they want to walk
in the building just so impressed with
him you know as a player as a person his
intelligence in the game the way he
studies and just you know his knowledge
overall just enjoy those conversations
so much so you know all that is is
really great and you know he and I are
just really like you said hoping that
football gets going here sooner than
later and we can all just get out of the
field and be normal and do what we do
but until then we're just trying to make
the best of it I know it's it's uh it's
dangerous isn't the word but I guess
dicey for to ask a coach in the NFL a
question about the media but why do you
think this is constantly a conversation
about Stafford and the Lions and maybe
he's been
offer or people are knocking on your
door for him why do you think that's a
constant drumbeat last couple of years
yeah that's a really good question and I
would say I have no idea I mean honestly
it's a lot of times I think people just
try to speculate or they you know throw
darts at the board see what sticks and
then people run with it so that's why I
from from that standpoint for us you
know we just kind of paint no I don't
say paint on mine but you just don't
know if intention to that you know it's
just all about doing what we do and
staying focused and moving forward so
you know certainly from that Avenue I
mean you could have as you could have
given me an honest Cincinnati answer and
I appreciate you didn't I appreciate
that you actually expounded on that Matt
I really appreciate that you know
speaking of that were you surprised that
Brady left the year-old spot were you
surprised that he's gonna be wearing
Tampa Bay pewter oh you know that's a
great question you know having been
there in a couple years I don't know if
I can really speak on any of that other
than the fact that you know I know Tom
is super competitive and he's a great
person he's a great guy I know Tampa
Tampa Bay is going to be real excited to
have him and he's going to go down there
and do everything he can to to try to
win certainly spent a lot of lot of
great years with Tom Brady and someone
that I just you know I love so much and
consider a really close friend and just
know that you know he's gonna go compete
and he loves to play this game and you
know wish them all the best you know
except when we play obviously do you
plan this year I'm trying to say I don't
think you do though do you reschedule we
do you know what I'm kind of embarrassed
I'm looking right now you do play him
you do play you did are you are you are
you were but when you do see him on week
16 it was in your house that Tom got his
first ever reps is a professional
quarterback on a Thanksgiving are you
aware that fact you know what I'm not
gonna lie to you I was not aware that's
my history day a little bit of Education
for me
well it's only fitting is you know he's
revered up the road from you as you know
revered have
I have definitely gone to that Stadium
with my kids taking some pictures and
maybe sent them to you know when I went
in the locker room you know cuz Jim
Harbaugh reached out to me to be an
honorary captain one day and I crushed
it you know although I I forgot what you
know he instructed me and the players to
call you know you know to ask for should
we Michigan I just we for the day when
the toss forgot what we were supposed to
do if we lost the toss and the players
at the time that we're out there Jake
but was on the team that time they
looked at me and I'm like I'm honorary
like I don't remember this thing and I
remember no so this is funny this is
funny so we go back to the sideline and
Harbaugh has already got his hands on
his knees he's focused right the ball is
about to be kicked off and this is after
I got introduced and pant fans cheered
and I doff my cap like I was Lou Gehrig
you know like I didn't know what the
hell to do so I go back I go back and he
stares at me and I think to myself did I
just screw up the toss and he looks at
me and he just suddenly breaks into
smile and goes hey nice ovation and I'm
like well I think I got it right but the
reason why I tell that story is I go in
the locker room that day there's one
picture of bo on the wall and two of Tom
Brady so that's all you need to know
yeah yeah I could see I could clue that
you know I think we got to get you out
here you know okay we didn't get that
right maybe you can come out to a Lions
game and you know look it is one of the
most stressful things as a head coach
you're trying to explain to the players
and you're just like okay am i screwing
this up or you gonna screw this up I
know the verbage is a little bit messed
up here I do a lot of hand signals I
make sure we point right there's trying
to be clear I try to use landmarks in
the stadium so you know there's nothing
worse especially you know what's so
funny is that indoor obviously it's
completely different than when you're
playing out to work right stadiums
especially late in the year and you know
I mean you could have like a Parcells
knowledge of your of your stadium know
that if a garage door is open there's a
draft or something like that you know
you may
there's there's been a few fans that
happened to come on once in a while I'm
not saying that doesn't happen every now
and then she's got a Southside Stadium
where you can open up a door you create
a little bit of a win there's that
sometimes those buttons is interesting
I'll just I'll just make a note I'll
make a mental note that hey before I let
you go we we mentioned here on our show
yesterday that up for some reason don't
worry about how it came up but it did
I've never seen the movie Roadhouse from
beginning and in so many or the movie
Point Break at all and my colleagues
here are very upset with me for that is
there a film that you've never seen that
you'd be embarrassed to admit that
you've never seen I know you're a
football coach and you're in the tank
many times watching game film and not
actually cinema but is there a movie
you've never seen that would be somewhat
embarrassing for you Matt Patricia to a
admit that you've never seen outstanding
question you sir um I'll say this I have
purposely not caught up yet on the Star
Wars movies because I just know that
when I watch them I cannot be
interrupted and I just got to sit down I
want to grind through all I have has a
huge Star Wars fan as a kid and growing
up just that is embarrassing to me that
I have yet to see those but but the old
Mark Hamill oh yeah Harrison Ford you
are you're locked in on that but the new
ones you ability 7 cinema cinema front
row giant screen like eating popcorn
probably too much yeah okay all right
man thanks for the call brother a great
chatting with you as always really
appreciate the time always always you
know always great to talk to you
appreciate everything that you do all
the time and thank you hope everyone's
healthy and I always appreciate your
support of my run for st. Jude you do
ever hear you're a generous man
coach appreciate that thank you thanks
so much right back at you that's Detroit
Lions head coach Matt Patricia hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here